à
jadis les peuples indo européen honorer
des dieux et des déesses qu'ils
associaient aux astres au cycle des
saisons et aux phénomènes atmosphériques
taranis est le dieu celtique du tonnerre
c'est l'un des principaux acteurs du
panthéon occidental son nom signifie
tonnerre en gaulois
c'est un proche cousin du germain tort
du romain jupiter
du grec zeus
et de là rien indra
tu est en bronze du châtelet trouvait en
haute-marne montre taranis tels que leur
présenter les anciens cents
le vieux barbu d'âge mûr se tient debout
il brandit le foudre de la main droite
et porte en bandoulière un cercle où
sont suspendus ds qui symbolisent les
éclairs
de la main gauche il agrippe une roue de
chars
cette roue caractérise si bien tard à
nice qu'elle suffit souvent à
l'identifier comme cette statuette dans
l'aisne
et ce relief en alsace
emblème à lui seul sous-entend le dieu
tel l'hôtel à la roue de nîmes
la statue en pierre de séguret trouver
dans le vaucluse présente un dieu dont
les attributs sont la roue l'aigle et le
serpent
taranis mesure ici deux mètres 06 la
roue 75 cm
le chaudron de gains des strips a été
découvert à la fin du 19e siècle dans
une tourbière du danemark
date est plus ou moins de l'époque du
christ ce chaudron rituel est constitué
de 13 plaque d'argent grave et d'image
mythologiques
une plaque montre taranis en bus et main
levée
on le reconnaît à deux attributs il
porte une barbe épaisse et les associer
à une roue
sur sa droite la roue est aussi tenus
par un personnage entier coiffé d'un
casque à cornes
et sous le guerrier au casque à cornes
glisse un serpent à tête de bélier la
scène est encadré en bas par trois devis
font pas sens le greffon est un hybride
mi aigles millions en eau par deux loups
contre passants
ainsi gain des strips et ségur et
montrent tous deux le dieu taranis
associé à la roue aux rapaces aigle ou
griffon et aux serpents
en occident la roue a été longtemps
honoré comme un symbole sacré telle
cette ruelle gauloise
cette ruelle en bronze du dijonnais
identifier ici comme un fermoir de
bourse peut avoir eu un sens plus
religieux qu'utilitaire et symbolisé la
roue de taranis
la roue que tient le céleste taranis
représente probablement le soleil
dans l'imaginaire des anciens celte
l'ennemi du monde étaient figurés par
une créature hybride le géant angui ped
ce géant est un humanoïde avec une queue
de serpent à la place des jambes
le rôle souverain de taranis consiste à
écraser cette chimère reptilienne
pour accomplir cette mission le maître
du ciel monte à cheval et des sabots de
sa monture il piétine le géant prostré à
terre
dans la sarre la colonne de
schwarzenegger en montre un bel exemple
de reconstitution coloré
en gaule le thème du cavalier alanguie
ped et fréquents le monument type se
présente sous la forme d'une immense
colonne
ses colonnes à taranis sont aussi
appelées colonnes à jupiter mais aucun
récit ni statut ne présente jamais le
jupiter originel à cheval
ce cavalier de seltz en alsace a tout
lieu d'être tard à nice
la colonne reconstituer d'arlon en
belgique offre un aperçu de ce que
pouvait donner dans l'antiquité une
colonne à taranis à la base un socle
carré montre quatre dieux un sur chaque
face
quasiment toujours il y a le baroudeur
hercules armé de son bâton associé à
trois acolytes divers
au dessus de cette pierre à quatre dieux
s'élance la colonne couverte parfois
d'un motif qui évoque des feuilles
superposés ou les corses d'un tronc
comme pour lui donner l'apparence d'un
arbre
en haut de la colonne repose un vaste
chapiteau à quatre côtés chaque phase
étant couverte d'un visage ces quatre
visages figurent peut-être des vents
aérien où les quatre saisons de l'année
enfin la cime domine tard à nice
les vestiges de ces monuments ne sont
jamais complet mais par des recoupements
on sait ce qu'il en était jadis ainsi
sur la colonne reconstitué du donon en
alsace on voit taralis à cheval qui
brandit son arme céleste le foudre
lancé au galop ou par une ruade son
destrier fougue foule le géant a que
deux reptiles
ne paraît même pas se défendre comme
apporte yeux dans les vosges
à plouaret en armorique malgré l'usure
du temps on devine encore la forme du
cheval les jambes de taranis et la
silhouette tendu et écraser du géant à
queue de serpent
aniche en auvergne la statue de taranis
a été refaite à l'identique
ces colonnes ne sont pas hommes
certaines comprennent au dessus de la
pierre à quatre dieux un second socle
comme à stuttgart en allemagne
en lorraine près de metz fut découverte
en 1878 la colonne de merton du cavalier
alanguie ped l'oeuvre total mesurait 12
mètres de haut
c'est l'une des plus complètes retrouvé
à ce jour
sur le chapiteau une dalle porte le
monstre andy ped que le destrier de
taranis écrase de ses sabots à l'épaule
et à la tête la victoire du dieu est
totale et paraît sans effort
à église neuve près billon dans le puy
de dôme le géant écrasé supporte avec
une sorte de résignation les sabots du
cheval de taranis
à grands dans les vosges à la place du
géant à queue de serpent on trouve un
petit humanoïde et les dons les elle
porte les sabots du puissant cheval
détail intéressant le bilan de ces
colonnes montre qu'en général la course
du cavalier semble orienté vers le
soleil levant
et il ne fait aucun doute qu'il s'agit
de taranis à auburn burg en bavière
taranis est parfaitement identifiable
avec son célèbre attribue la roue qu'il
porte ici en guise de bouclier
ses colonnes à taranis sont présents
dans toute la gaule chevelue avec une
forte densité dans le nord-est elles
sont absentes en revanche de la
narbonnaise
datés des 2e 3e siècle les colonnes à
taranis atteignent sans doute leur
apogée à l'époque de l'empiré gaulois
cet événement méconnu a joué un rôle
crucial dans la renaissance de la
culture celtique dès la période romaine
en 260 points de bascule du monde
antique la bureaucratie romaine
l'autorité militaire et la monnaie
s'effondre
l' empire romain présidée par le faible
gallien cesse de fait d'exister en
occident
[Musique]
à cette anarchie civile s'ajoutent la
porosité des frontières des invasions
barbares venus de germanie commence
d'enfoncer le rhin
l'occident est en ruine mais il conserve
un potentiel de relèvement
pour pallier cette déliquescence de
l'état il faudrait un homme providentiel
un homme en qui la remet et confiance et
en qui le peuple place son salut
cet homme là c'est un général gaulois du
nom de posture
en gaule même sous l' empire l'armée a
toujours eu une forte composante à
cheval
posthume mobilise donc la cavalerie
gauloise et refoulent les envahisseurs
au delà du rhin
[Musique]
comme l'expliquent en trop peu de mots
une chronique de l'antiquité tardive
l'histoire auguste
posture fut accueillie favorablement par
toute l'armée et les gaulois qu'il pût
s'employer pendant sept ans à restaurer
les gaules tandis que gagner à traîner
dans la débauche les tavernes et se
consume et d'amour pour une femme
barbares tous les peuples gaulois avait
de l'affection pour posthume parce
qu'après avoir repoussé les tribus
germaniques il avait ramené la sécurité
d'autres fois dans l' empire romain
la gaule libérer le victorieux posthume
se fait alors proclamé empereur des
gaules fx sa capitale à cologne face au
danger
lempire gaulois comprend la gaule la
bretagne libéré
enfin le nouvel empereur redresse
l'économie en battant monnaie la
numismatique apporte un précieux
témoignage de la qualité et de la
quantité des monnaies de posthume
la monnaie est un média essentiel de
l'ancien temps pas roussir que
l'information promu directement par le
pouvoir en personne
la connexion entre un texte d'époque qui
a valeur de témoignage et une monnaie
qui a valeur de preuve matérielle est
des plus intéressantes sur une face
posthume apparaît de profil droit il est
barbu et porte une couronne radier le
titre est imperator kaïssa repose tout
moss pius félix au goût ce tous
c'est-à-dire empereur césar posthume
pieux heureux auguste
sur l'autre face la gaule a les traits
d'une femme drapée elle porte une coiffe
crénelés et tient une corne d'abondance
elle est agenouillé en signe de
remerciement et donne sa main à posthume
posthume d'étuis cyan soldat a le pied
droit posé sur un ennemi vaincu il tient
une lance de la main gauche de la droite
il prend délicatement la main de la
gaule comme pour la relever le titre et
restitue tort gallia room c'est à dire
restaurateur au sauveur de la gaule le
latin est au pluriel les gaules mais
l'image montre une seule femme donc il
s'agit bien de la gaule
texte et monnet parle ici du même
événement historique l'empereur gaulois
posthume avait habille la gaule dans sa
liberté
cette affirmation de lempire gaulois
dont le coeur est au nord-est apporte
une explication plausible à la forte
présence des colonnes à taranis
précisément dans cette région
la mythologie de taranis dieu du ciel
qui terrasse les ténèbres et par
analogie assimilé à posthume l'empereur
gaulois qui terrasse les pare balles
à l'avenir la recherche historique
gagnerait à se pencher davantage sur l'
empire gaulois cela peut surprendre
notre époque mais posthume est
apparemment le chef d'état de notre pays
le plus identifiable avant l'an mil si
l'on s'en tient à la matière
archéologiques donc à l'exclusion des
textes
après l'épisode séparatistes qui aura vu
coexister lempire gaulle ou en occident
lempire de palmyre en orient et l'
empire romain résiduelles au centre
vient le temps de recoller les trois
provinces
à la fin du 3ème siècle pacifiquement
ont refait des relents pire qui n'a plus
de romain que le nom est longue et
instaure aussitôt un nouveau type de
régime
la dyarchie la dyarchie consiste à
diviser lempire en deux moitiés autonome
aux frontières encore imprécises
l'orient et l'occident
par une meilleure localisation du
pouvoir on espère pallier le manque de
réactivité d'un régime trop centralisée
désormais il y aura deux empereurs
dioclétien qui gouvernera lorient et
maximien l'occident
ma mère fin est un orateur gaulois de la
fin du 3ème siècle
l'antiquité tardive et l'âge d'or du
panégyrique un style littéraire fait des
loges et de satire de culture générale
et d'anecdotes qui composent dans un
langage codé un hymne à l'empereur
régnant
ce genre inique et la réminiscence d'une
coutume celtique le panégyriste
occupants en effet la fonction du barde
d'antan
ma mère tu as un composé deux
panégyrique daté de 289 et 290 en
l'honneur de l'empereur d'occident
maximien
certains passages offre des digressions
théologique dont le contenu va
grandement nous éclairer
[Musique]
notre barda voulu traiter ce partage de
l' empire en rattachant les deux
empereurs à deux immortels
dioclétien est associé aux dieux céleste
du tonnerre jupiter
maximien au héros terrestres de la force
hercules
dans cette vision théologique le partage
déroulé précis jupiter dioclétien
commandes hercules maximien réalise
de même que tous les biens partagé entre
le ciel et la terre nous semblent
provenir du pouvoir de diverses
divinités mais découle en fait des dieux
souverain jupiter maîtres du ciel et
hercules pacificateur de la terre de
même dans toutes les plus belles choses
que ceux celles qui sont faites sous la
conduite des autres c'est dioclétien qui
entreprend et c'est tout à maximilien
qui accomplit
on aura noté la singularité de ce
partage du monde entre les dieux jupiter
et hercule le maître du ciel entreprend
le héros terrestre accompli
se partagent contractuelle n'est pas
tirée de la culture gréco romaine
les noms d'emprunt de jupiter et
hercules sont ici contractualiser d'une
façon tout à fait insolite qui ne
s'explique que par une référence
théologique à leurs correspondants
gaulois
mamertin évoque en effet clairement la
dyarchie jupiter hercules jupiter est le
dieu céleste qui détient l'autorité et
reculer le héros terrestre qui combat
par la force
cette union sacrée n'est pas gréco
romaine car les reculs y remplit le rôle
d'un héros rejeté du ciel qui doit
relever le défi des 12 travaux comme
punition envoyé par la déesse héra
ni la grèce ni rom n'offrent un binôme
état physique qui lui dirai clairement
hausse et recul la foudre et le bâton
pour ensemble vaincre les monstres et
régenter les affaires du monde
pourtant c'est bien ce binôme là que
promeut mamertin à l'instar d'ailleurs
des colonnes à taranis
[Musique]
cette complémentarité entre l'autorité
céleste et le combat de terrain est en
effet illustré sur les colonnes celtique
à l'asim lecavalier impérial 2000 le
monde à la base avec d'autres
personnages le héros hercules armé de
son bâton et prêts à la lutte
l'organigramme de mamertin coïncide donc
avec les fameuses colonnes où le dieu de
souveraineté est assistée du héros de
puissance
curieusement un rapport quasi christique
lit ce père céleste et son fils descendu
sur terre pour agir au plus près des
hommes
dans un autre panégyrique mamertin
complète son portrait mythologique de
jupiter le dieu chasse à d'abord du ciel
les titans puis il affronta
d'énigmatiques créatures à double forme
enfin détail totalement absent de la
mythologie gréco-romaine par un vif et
long du ciel ce dieu du tonnerre aurait
inversé le cours du soleil
[Musique]
en vérité le modèle de dioclétien c'est
le dieu qui jadis expulsa les titans du
domaine céleste et qui ensuite bataille
à contre les monstres à double forme
d'un soin perpétuelle il gouverne un
empire bien établie et préserve avec
vigilance lors de l'alternance de toute
chose
car il est en mouvement non seulement
lorsqu il suscite le tonnerre et lance
la foudre mais même après avoir dompté
les forces élémentaires il arrange
encore les destins et d'une céleste
pousser ils inversent le cours du
brillant soleil
ces textes du 3ème siècle vont éclairer
la plaque du chaudron de guindé ce truc
ou deux personnages ressortent
le dieu taranis commandes au ciel il
touche la route solaire et semble même
la confondre avec sa main droite l'autre
personnage plus petits tels
aéroterrestre tient la roue solaire dans
ses mains il a tout l'air d'assister le
dieu du tonnerre
en bas le serpent est situé précisément
sous le héros sa tête de bélier
bizarrement retourné juste sous la roue
indique peut-être l'inversion de la
courbe du soleil comme évoqué dans le
texte ainsi le texte de mamertin aide à
interpréter un relief mythologique gravé
sur le chaudron antique
on résumer au cours du 3ème siècle la
renaissance celtic se confirme sous tous
les plans
politico militaire avec la naissance de
l'empiré gaulois et la victoire de
posthume sur les barbares
économique avec le battage de monnaie
artistique avec l'érection des colonnes
de victoire à taranis et hercules mêlant
grandeur du nouvel empire et mythologie
celtique
littéraire enfin avec des références
théologiques odieux céleste et aux héros
terrestre des gaulois sous les noms
d'emprunt plus conventionnel de jupiter
et hercule
les chansons de geste française diffusée
en occident entre les 11e et 13e siècles
sont le fruit chrétiens de l'ancien
paganisme de la gaule
le souverain de cette matière de france
et charlemagne
après et j
biographe de l'empereur des francs ces
mêmes charlemagne en personne qui aurait
ordonné de mettre à l'écrit la culture
orale du vaste royaume
les poèmes barbara et antique où était
chanté la geste et l'égard des anciens
rois charlemagne les fit écrire pour les
confiera la mémoire
ce sont ces poèmes transcrit sur ordre
de charlemagne qui nous sont parvenues
poèmes qui met en scène charlemagne lui
même et les douze paires de france
mythologie celtique oriente les
aventures des héros et c'est cette
mythologie qui leur octroie des
attributs particulier
la barbe du souverain va en offrir un
bon exemple il n'existe aucune statue
certaines figures en charlemagne la
seule statue est parfois identifié un
roi carolingien par est en réalité
beaucoup plus tardive
et ginard a personnellement connu
l'empereur des francs
or dans son texte la seule barbe dont il
parle est celle des derniers rois
mérovingiens dit fainéants qui aurait
arboré une barbe pendantes en plus d'une
longue chevelure
en fait l'unique indices se trouve sur
une monnaie qui porte en légende carolus
imperator au goût de tous
charles empereur auguste
il s'agit probablement de charlemagne
l'empereur a le visage massif le crâne
rond le nez long le coup et paix et
cours ce qui coïncide bien avec la
description qu'en données gina à
l'évidence toutefois le portrait
monétaire et glabre tout indique que le
vrai charlemagne ne portait pas de bar
or la barbe c'est précisément la tribu
principal du charlemagne de nos poèmes
l'expression la plus fréquentée qui
revient comme un refrain lui alloue une
barbe fleurie c'est à dire épaisse
longue et blanche
c'est sous un pin près d'un églantiers
qu'on a fait un trône tout d'or pur la
siège le roi qui tient d'où ce france il
à la barbe blanche et la tête toute
fleurie il a le corps noble et la lure
fier
à comparer les barbes le charlemagne
légendaire a donc plus de similitudes
avec taranis voir curieusement avec
l'empereur gaulois posthume qu'avec le
charlemagne historique glabre
on note au passage que dans les deux
gestes charlemagne est souvent associé
aux arbres auprès desquels il trône
or les colonnes épique où culminent
taranis présente parfois se trompent
grave et de feuilles ou des corses comme
pour rappeler le thème de l'arbre
autre exemple on a vu que taranis
portait le foudre en passant du domaine
des dieux à celui des hommes l'arme
lumineuse a évidemment dû s'adapter aux
plausible
l'épée de charlemagne s'appelle joyeuse
est là précisément la particularité de
rayonner 30 fois par jour
charlemagne à sa joyeuse à jamais sans
égal qui changent l'éclat 30 fois par
jour
multiplicité lumineuse qui serait la
réminiscence des éclairs chez taranis on
observe la même multiplicité de larmes
rendu par les nombreuses guest suspendu
à son épaule les similitudes entre
charlemagne taranis ne s'arrête pas là
tout comme taranis sûr o drom de gains
d'hestrud à son bras droit associé à la
roue et aux héros casque et charlemagne
à son bras droit associé à roland
la chanson de roland apporte à ce sujet
une réponse sans ambiguïté
le traître ganelon est partie comploté
avec marcil le roi des sarrazins il
propose à l'ennemi un plan diabolique
qui prévoit la mort de roland et la
défaite de douce france gars de long 10
qui pourrait faire que roland mourut
dans la bataille alors charles perdrait
le bras droit de son corps des
formidables armée sans rembourserait et
charles ne rassemblerait plus jamais de
ses grandes forces la terre des ancêtres
retournerai au repos
loin d'être une simple expression ce
bras droit est un élément capital du
récit
plus loin en effet charlemagne fait un
songe prémonitoire qui confirme la
trahison de ganelon contre les francs la
scène onirique volontiers archaïsante
montre charlemagne mordu au bras droit
par le sanglier gallo long puis à saillé
par le léopard marcil tandis que le
chien roland surgi à son secours
le jour s'en va la nuit est tombée le
puissant empereur charles d'or il fait
un songe il était au plus haut col de 6
et tenait salle en salle à amp de
fresnes pour le compte de ganelon la lui
saisit des mains il l'a secoué la jta si
violemment que les éclats s'envolèrent
jusqu'au ciel charles darwin s'éveille
pas après ce songe il a une autre vision
il était en france dans sa chapelle
d'aix a semblé très cruel gars ne l'ont
lu mordait le bras droit des ardennes il
vit venir à léopard marcil qui avec
fureur l'aca vite en personne depuis la
salle des valin à votre rôle en charbon
et par sow il a couru à challes il
tranche ad'abord l'oreille droite du
sanglier puis avec colère qu'on bâtit le
léopard
si le héros casqués peut anticiper
roland qu'en est il de la roue
la bataille qui suit est le fruit d'une
trahison dont le fourbe ganelon est
l'instigateur et d'un guet-apens dans
les montagnes pyrénéennes
ayant reçu des gages de soumission de la
part des sarrasins l'armée chrétienne
quitte l'espagne et fait route vers la
france en une longue colonne à travers
les vallées à brut
l'empereur charlemagne dirige
l'avant-garde tandis que son meilleur
capitaine roland couvre l'arrière-garde
dangereusement vulnérables
[Musique]
or c'est un piège l'ennemi de la foi a
en réalité rassembler son immense armée
au col de roncevaux les mécréants se
jette sur l'armée franck et attaques
dans le dos l'arrière garde
[Musique]
roland olivier l'archevêque turpin et
leurs compagnons résiste comme ils
peuvent mais ploient sous le nombre
[Musique]
roland se résigne à souffler son
oliphant de toutes ses forces pour
alerter charlemagne de la trahison et du
désastre
il y souffle si fort qu'ils sauront
l'attend jusqu'au sang
quand de l'autre côté des pyrénées
charlemagne entend au loin retentir
l'olifant il comprend ce qu'il se passe
et fait aussitôt arrêté le traître gars
de l'eau
l'armée chrétienne rebrousse alors
chemin et galope au secours de roland et
de l'arrière-garde dessinée
mais trop tard les douze paires de
france héroïque gisent morts sur le
champ de bataille
[Musique]
c'est là que va intervenir un phénomène
surprenant qui rapproche encore des
francs du dieu celtique tard à nice
en tant que dieu du tonnerre taranis est
à l'évidence un personnage céleste c'est
pourquoi la roue associé à son grade roi
a tout lieu d'être une roue elle aussi
céleste tel le soleil
charlemagne voudrait venger son neveu
mais le soleil décline et l'ennemi
profit du crépuscule pour s'échapper
alors l'ampleur des francs se mettent en
prière est aussitôt se produit un
miracle le soleil s'immobilise dans le
ciel
cette prière est essentielle aucun autre
personnage n'accomplit une action de ce
genre c'est l'un des aspects de la
fonction souveraine
[Musique]
par son autorité quasi céleste
charlemagne exercice' un pouvoir
surnaturel sur le monde
du ciel descente alors un ange qui dit
au roi d'enfourcher son cheval car la
lumière l'accompagnera dans son combat
quand le roi voit décliner le soir ils
descendent par mais après sur l'herbe
verte il se couche à terre et prie le
seigneur dieu de faire s'arrêter le
soleil retarder la nuit est demeuré le
jour l'ange dit charles monte à cheval
car à toi ne faillit pas à la clarté
une chronique confirme la tradition
poétique le soleil va illuminer le ciel
pendant trois jours
pendant que charles chevauchée sans
relâche avec toute sa baronnie il a tu
vas que le soleil s'arrêta et resta
immobile pendant trois jours
comme on pouvait s'y attendre dans une
lutte quasi cosmique qui oppose la
lumière divine à l'obscurité démoniaque
la rue et chrétienne terrasses les
sarrasins en un lieu au nom évocateur
leval ténèbres
pour charlemagne dieu fit un grand
miracle car le soleil est resté immobile
les païens fui les francs les
pourchassent ils les atteignent ovale
ténèbres le cours de l'ebre et de vente
e l'epa lien avec l'intel de leurs dieux
terreau wagon puis saute dans l'eau sans
protection
certains culto font d'autres s'en vont
au gré du courant les france s'écrit
malheur à vous d'avoir vu roland
le dieu terreau wagon est une
réminiscence du dieu gaulois tard votre
égard anus le taureau trois grues tel
qu'on le voit sur le célèbre pilier des
nautes à paris
par cette référence aux taureaux
mythique de la gaule la fin de la
bataille de roncevaux sonne comme un
ancien sacrifice rituel
c'est sans doute ce taureau que l'on
rencontre déjà sur le chaudron de garder
ce truc sur une plaque latérale et rosé
bovidés sont présentés trois fois dans
ce qui s'apparente à un duel
finalement vaincu le taureau j maur dans
le val ténèbres du chaudron si l'on peut
dire à savoir la plaque du fonds
o drom de garder ce truc et chanson de
rolland se font donc écho à travers les
siècles car ils sont façonnés de la même
matière celtique
la composante principale peut se résumer
ainsi le roi barbu active la route
solaire cette composante précise se
retrouve dans l'iconographie du dieu
gaulois taranis dans le texte
gallo-romain de mamertin ou jupiter
taranis inverse le cours du soleil et
dans les textes médiévaux français ou
charlemagne immobilise le soleil
une telle pérennité ne laisse pas de
surprendre
jusqu'à nos jours des coutumes
régionales ont conservé des rituels de
l'ancien culte solaire
à la saint jean d'été ont réuni le
village au sommet d'une colline qui
domine une rivière
quand tombe la nuit on en flammes une
roue bourré de paille
puis on projette la roue de feu en aval
pour lui faire dévaler la pente jusqu'à
la rivière
si la roue de feu s'échoue en cours de
route cécile de disette
mais si elle atteint la rivière ces
signes de bonnes récoltes à venir
le lien entre soleil et roux de feu est
évident vu que ce rituel à lui à la
saint jean d'été quand après avoir
atteint son point culminant le soleil ne
peut plus désormais que redescendre du
ciel
ce rituel médiévale consiste donc à
reproduire l'action de charlemagne la
scène principale est une roue de feu qui
illumine la nuit la scène finale est une
chute dans la rivière
il s'agit là d'un héritage qui dépasse
l'horizon celtique pour atteindre
l'espace indo européen
en inde au pays des aryens le dieu indra
offre en effet des similitudes
intéressante avec taranis
non seulement indra et le roi du ciel et
le dieu du tonnerre mais lui aussi est
associée à la roue solaire
un mythe raconte en effet comment indra
a jadis au thé ou briser une roue du
char du soleil il est en outre
explicitement dit que c'est par cette
action qu'il a pu vaincre les ennemis
des dieux
indra a brisé la route du soleil car sa
force est irrésistible mais en même
temps cette roue qu'est lancé dans
l'espace et sur qui repose la vie de
tous a été sauvé de la destruction
c'est alors qu'en faveur de tes amis
malheureux tu as des tâches et une roue
du soleil seul tu as lutté contre tous
ses vieux ennemis au indra lui a donné
la mort au plus lisible
indra fait donc exactement comme
charlemagne et taranis leroy triomphe de
ses opposants après avoir exercé une
action contraignante sur le soleil indra
casse la roue du soleil et 20 les dieux
ennemis charlemagne immobilise le soleil
et 20 l'epag un ennemi par anis jupiter
inverse la course du soleil et 20 les
monstres by forme
ainsi l'iconographie de taranis et la
légende de charlemagne trouve un écho
favorable dans la cosmogonie d'hydra
structurellement tard alice et indra
sont les héritiers celtique et védique
de l'antique dieu du tonnerre des
peuples indo européen
selon la légende la mort de roland donne
lieu à un événement climatique de ne
porter inhabituelle en france elle
déclenche une tempête apocalyptique
ce ténébreux orages augmenté de
secousses sismiques rapproche aussi la
chanson de roland de l'iconographie de
taranis lui même porteur d'éclairs et de
foudre la colère divine idées pour un
déchaînement élémentale pour roland qui
n'est pas sans similitudes avec le
vendredi saint
en france éclater une tourmente son
naturel bourrasques de tonnerre et de
vent pluie et grêle démesuré chu de la
foudre dans ces grues en vrai c'est un
tremblement de terre un millier sont
immenses ténèbres pas de clarté sauf
quand les clercs fend le ciel nul homme
ne vois cela sans être saisie dépôt
vente plusieurs disent c'est la
consommation des temps la fin du monde
qui maintenant nous accable cela ne
savent pas ils ne disent pas l'évidence
c'est le grand deuil pour la mort de
roland
kylie a connection thématiques entre la
retraite de roland à travers le col de
roncevaux et la retraite du soleil après
le solstice d'été
roncevaux est censé avoir eu lieu le 15
août 778
un dernier détail étymologique en langue
gauloise la roue la course se dit rothau
or le nom originel de roland et rockland
il s'agit certes là d'un nom germanique
est sans rapport avec la roue
mais il est troublant que le bras droit
de taranis soit un héros casque est liée
à une auto et que le bras droit de
charlemagne soir claude tout se passe
comme si le nom germanique avait été
choisi pour sa proximité phonétique avec
le nom celtique de héros originel en
rapport avec la roue
ainsi qu'il s'agisse de la barbe de
charlemagne de son épée joyeuse de son
bras droit roland du soleil immobile
dans le ciel de la tempête apocalyptique
où d'étymologie la chanson de rolland
est clair la plaque de taris
lors de la grande dispersion des peuples
indo européen une partie migra vers
l'occident tels les celtes les germains
les latins tandis qu'une autre partie
sans aller vers l'orient
gagnant l'inde et l'iran les aryens
fondèrent de brillantes civilisations
qui nous sont donc apparentés
les brahmanes en inde forme la caste
religieuse un clergé structuré qui
ressemble par certains aspects odroid
celtique
à ceci près que pour transmettre la
culture ancestrale les druides auront
privilégié l'oral tandis que les
brahmanes ont très tôt confié la leur à
l'écrit
leur langue et le sanscrit le rig veda
est un recueil de prières qui forment
aujourd'hui encore l'une des bases de la
religion védique et indienne
les hymne de louange à indra vont
montrer les liens étroits qui unissent
indra et tard à nice
et surtout les liens possibles avec l'un
de leurs ennemis respectifs celui d'
indra pouvant éclairer celui de taranis
en inde l'exploit le plus célèbre dînera
consiste à affronter un géant du nom de
vrie tra
le rite rat est un immense nuage qui en
emprisonnant les eaux dans le ciel cause
la sécheresse du sol et la misère des
récoltes alors il devra dieu du tonnerre
intervient
son nom sion et c'est un élément
important se fait sans difficulté mais
avec une autorité souveraine
de sa foudre le dieu perce le nuage les
eaux du nuage sont libérés la pluie
fertilisantes ramène l'abondance sur
terre
le puissante indra a touché de sa foudre
ces nuages qui lui si elle n'arrivait
pas à la surface de la terre frites rhin
dessèche la terre de sa foudre puissante
indra le frappe m incomparable à toi de
lancer ta foudre sur vitra et fait
couler des torrents de pluie
le professeur de mythologie comparer
georges dumézil a ainsi résumé l'exploit
fondamentale quoi que fasse il dînera
foudroyant en combat singulier
l'aquatique vrie tra
cet exploit qui à de telles conséquences
qui votait dratel renom une telle
puissance semble n'avoir pas même été
difficile n'avoir pas pris la forme d'un
duel au risque partagé en somme cette
grosse choses inertes menacer la vie du
monde plutôt économiquement que
belliqueuse mans ils avaient barré les
eaux des rivières avaient été dévorés
par le serpent
cette structure 1-2 européenne peut se
résumer ainsi le dieu du tonnerre
traversent facilement une masse
aquatique informe et passive
en inde le climat alterne sécheresse et
mousson d'où la lutte dînera contre un
nuage capteurs d'eau de pluie en france
le climat étant différent la structure a
été adapté à la place de la percée de
nuages on trouve semble-t-il la
traversée d'un fleuve
le fleuve est vu comme le nuage une
masse à la fois aquatique passive et
entravant la bonne marche du monde
sur les fameuses colonnes en effet que
fêtards à nice il s'avance à cheval en
piétinant une créature coucher sans
défense comme pour indra il n'y a pas
vraiment de duels mais plutôt un acte
d'autorité
la structure est identique mais ce qui
entrave est inversé conséquence des
adaptations géoclimatique des peuples en
inde le nuage retient l'eau en france le
fleuve déborde de dos
mais la structure est très claire en
inde comme en france le dieu du tonnerre
indra ou taranis traversent facilement
avec la foudre ou à cheval la masse
aquatique informe et passive nuage au
fleuve
ainsi le géant à la force passive est un
monstre composé d'eau soit le nuage que
traverse la foudre dînera soit le fleuve
que traverse taranis à cheval
[Musique]
les textes médiévaux confirme-t-il cette
interprétation
comme on va le voir le charlemagne
légendaire et là encore l'héritier du
dieu taranis non seulement les textes le
confirme mais il indique la raison pour
laquelle le roi traverse le fleuve
tout commence par un songe prémonitoire
il va à charles une vision où il voyait
un chemin des toiles quand charles vu
plusieurs nuits le chemin des toiles il
commença par se demander ce que cela
pouvait être
saint jacques lui explique le sens de
cette vision onirique qui doit mener
charlemagne à compostelle en galice
le chemin des toiles que tu as vu
signifie que tu dois aller de france en
galice avec une grande armée pour
combattre les sarrasins délivrer ma
route et mater visiter mon église et
m'en tombent aux attaques suite iront à
pèlerinage tous les peuples qui sont
d'une mer à l'autre pour chercher le
pardon de leur faute auprès de notre
seigneur jésus-christ
ce chemin des toiles ou chemins de saint
jacques est un autre nom pour désigner
la voie lactée
compostelle signifie étymologiquement le
champ des toiles
l'allemagne doit suivre la voie lactée
qui le conduira jusqu'au champ des
toiles
bientôt en travers de ça marche la
gironde
charlemagne se met alors en prière et
tout à coup surgit un cervidé qui lui
indique l'emplacement du gué
le roi charles mal se mit alors en route
avec son armée et par bateau fleuve qui
s'appelle la gironde et ils ne
trouvèrent là ni gai ni bac et il ne
savait pas comment traverser alors le
roi charlemagne tomba en prière et
demanda à dieu de leur faciliter le
passage du fleuve s'il voulait qu'ils
aillent en espagne tu as complète alors
un miracle pour le roi charlemagne une
biche blanche traversa le fleuve à b et
il chevauche heurte à sa suite
cette traversée des six il est facile du
fleuve par charlemagne derrière un
cervidé se trouve aussi dans d'autres
récits
dans quasiment les mêmes termes en effet
le roi clovis sur mon déjà cette épreuve
à la fois aisé est cruciale après avoir
reçu un présage favorable de saint
martin à tour clovis part en guerre
contre alaric le roi des wisigoths
mais sur son enfin il se heurte à une
rivière en crue la vienne
alors ils prient dieu au matin suivant
survient une biche géante qui révèle où
est le gain
plus tard lorsqu'il fut arrivé avec son
arme et le vent la vienne clovis ne
savais pas du tout en quel lieu il y
faudrait traverser la rivière qu'une
inondation de plus avaient gonflé alors
cette nuit-là il pria le seigneur de
bien vouloir lui montrer le guépard où
il pourrait à traverser dès le matin à
la volonté de dieu une biche d'une hta
extraordinaire entre de vente dans la
rivière alors qu'elle passe aguets les
hommes reconnaissent par où ils pourront
traverser
le rôle permanent du cervidé auprès des
roi clovis et charlemagne laisse
supposer que jadis kern une hausse le
duo un mur de serre devait plus ou moins
remplir le même rôle auprès du souverain
tard à nice
c'est ce que semble indiquer une plaque
du chaudron de gains des strips ou tard
à nice reconnaissable à sa barbe fleurie
brandit fièrement de ces rames et par
les pattes arrière comme des trophées de
chasse
il est probable qu'à l'instar de
charlemagne clovis taranis se soient
lancés à la poursuite de cervidés au
moment de la traversée d'un espace
considéré comme aquatique fleuve nuages
ou voie lactée
on résumer le roi seul détenteur de
l'autorité accompli l'exploit à la fois
simple et décisif de passer à travers
une masse d'eau géante
charlemagne traverse l'estuaire de la
gironde
clovis traverse la vienne en crue indra
perse de sa foudre le nuage capteurs
d'eau taranis enfin piétine le géant
serpent qui barrent la route du ciel
la chanson de roland peut-elle éclairé
des chapiteaux d'église
dans l'anjou l'église de cuno se dresse
au bord de la loire à 100 mètres du
fleuve
l'édifice est orienté au solstice soleil
le vent d'hiver ou soleil couchant d'été
il s'agit de l'une des plus grandes
églises romanes de france haute et très
lumineuse elle mesure 73 mètres de long
pour 27 m de large
son décor d'une excès lionel beauté
présente plus de 200 relief
très peu de ces reliefs ont un possible
rapport avec la bible
[Musique]
comme souvent dans les églises dites
romane en france les images gravées
affiche des thèmes payen d'origine
celtique
[Musique]
l'un des plus beaux chapiteaux de
l'église est située dans la nef du côté
sud ouest la séquence présente les
scènes suivantes
à droite trône une chouette géante qui
est harcelé par une nuée d'oiseaux
d'urnes beaucoup plus petit qu elle
certains oiseaux sont autour d'elle et
agressent sa tête ou son corps
d'autres juché sur la corne se penche
vers elle et piaillent dans sa direction
si l'on s'en tient à un langage
symbolique de bon sens le rapace
nocturne et comme repoussé par des
volatiles du urnes le jour tant de
repousser la nuit
juste à côté de la chouette un homme
moustachu souffle sa corne qu'il tient
dans sa main droite tandis qu'il agrippe
un bâton dans sa gauche
sa jambe droite élevé le relief brisé
laisse penser que l'homme posait son
pied sur quelque chose tel un rocher
comme pour figurer qu'il est dans la
montagne
pour ces deux relief continue on peut
imaginer roland dans les hauteurs de
roncevaux soufflant son dos leaf ans
tandis que déjà tombe la nuit
à côté se tient un homme barbu étant de
dos il se retourne en direction du
souffleur de corne on pense ici à
charlemagne qui au son de lolif en fait
demi tour pour rejoindre roland
vient ensuite ce qui semble être la
scène principale de la séquence l'homme
barbu affronte un lion à mains nues il
chevauche le fauve et lui tient la
gueule ouverte
à quoi correspond cette scène
dans la chanson de roland les songes
prémonitoire sont les éléments les plus
archaïques de la geste
l'homme que charlemagne affrontera en
duel à la bataille de saragosse à savoir
l'émir balligand et présenté sous la
forme d'un lion féroce dans la vision
onirique
un lion que l'empereur francs affront à
mains nues
du fond d'un bois arrive vers lui un
grand lyon très cruel vaillant farouche
qui la saillie et l'attaquant personnes
ils se prennent à bras le corps pour
lutter mais il ne sait lequel va lequel
tombent l'empereur ne s'est pas réveillé
cet ensemble de scènes successives et
précise de l'église de cuno correspond
donc parfaitement à des scènes épiques
de la chanson de rolland
si l'on résume dans la chanson de geste
et sur le chapiteaux historiés on
obtient la séquence structurelles
suivante une action surnaturelle
repousse la nuit charlemagne prix et le
soleil s'arrête dans le ciel où les
oiseaux diurnes chasse la chouette
géante dans la montagne le jeune héros
roland souffle son oliphant pour alerter
du péril en cours
celui à qui s'adresse l'olifant
charlemagne entend le message fait demi
tour et s'en retourne enfin de ses
propres mains le vieux barbu charlemagne
affronte le lion balligand
ajoutons qu'à côté du duel comme lyon
une scène montre un homme couché au sol
et les mains jointes
tel un mort
sa nuque est adossé au genou d'un
personnage ah si peut être une femme au
dessus comme en lévitation un personnage
barbu semble toucher les yeux du défunt
on peut y voir la mort de roland avec sa
fiancée aude et un ange
selon la légende saint gabriel aurait
récupéré le gant de roland et emmener
son âme au paradis
[Musique]
l'abbaye de graville situé en seine
maritime est intégré au havre a été
fondée au xième siècle
[Musique]
la nef contient au sommet des colonnes
de nombreux chapiteaux historiés au sens
mystérieux
[Musique]
côté sud de la nef une scène présente un
cavalier
il tient la brique du cheval de la main
gauche tandis que de la droite il
brandit en arrière une épée comme pour
prendre son élan avant de frapper
surtout sa main droite jouxte une grande
roue à quatre rayons
il est frappant de retrouver ici les
attributs même du dieu taranis un homme
à cheval très clairement associée à une
roue
deux autres roues accompagne notre
cavalier lune contient une fleur à huit
pétales
l'autre 13 rayons
notre cavalier à l'épée galope au devant
d'un cavalier à la lance on peut
s'attendre à un duel
enfin
lien la roue de cervidés avec ramure
sont en train de paître
si l'on met en parallèle le cavalier de
graville avec charlemagne est tard à
nice on obtient d'évidentes
correspondance notre cavalier est
associée à la roue tel taranis qui
agrippe sa roue et charlemagne qui
immobilise la roue solaire notre
cavalier est un guerrier tel charlemagne
il brandit son épée au ciel tel taranis
son foudre enfin notre cavalier va au
devant de cervidés tel charlemagne
traversant la gironde et par anis
capturant de serre
en résumé relief celtique de l'antiquité
relief d'églises médiévales et chansons
de geste recèle malgré les siècles le
même contenu mythologique
chaque domaine culturel peut aider à
éclairer les deux autres
les monnaies antiques offre des scènes
intéressantes à étudier
dans l'ancienne gaule l'animal le plus
représenté sur les monnaies et de loin
le cheval au naturel ou avec une tête
humaine ce qui en fait alors une sorte
de centaure
sur une monnaie dont joue daté du 1er
siècle avant notre ère on voit un cheval
à tête humaine il est au galop vers la
droite ils renversent une créature
humanoïde et les qui tombent face contre
terre
le centaure tire un char dont on
aperçoit la roue et qui est montée par
un conducteur
devant le cheval pas un fanion ici à
trois bandes
avec des variantes cette séquence
précise anticipe de façon frappante la
scène du cavalier alanguie ped où le
cheval de taranis piétine de ses sabots
le monstre coucher au sol ici l'équipage
équestre piétine une créature humanoïde
et les tout comme le tard à nice de
grand dans les vosges
[Musique]
sur les monnaies il s'agit souvent d'un
cocher et non d'un cavalier comme sur
cette monnaie des vénètes
la tribu des aulerques présente une
monnaie ou c'est un centaure pourvu dell
qui piétine l'humanoïde coucher au sol
chez les ismes dans le finistère le
cocher et stylisés en grosse tête et le
chevalet comme guidé par une croix au
bout d'une corde que tient le conducteur
ce qui fait obstacle à l'équipage
équestre varie chez les picton le cheval
à visage d'homme passe sur une main
dressé est une sorte de joux
chez les filles et dont le même équipage
bondi par dessus une roue à quatre ou
huit rayons
[Musique]
chez les zambiens le cheval saute par
dessus une grosse sphère entouré de
plusieurs petites
chez les rênes le cheval saute par
dessus une sphère entouré d'une sorte de
halo brillant
enfin je aulerques le cheval est
encadrée au dessus et en dessous par
deux sphères entouré d'un cercle
chez les et demain le cheval saute par
dessus une lyre
[Musique]
le cheval est parfois associée à
l'oiseau qui vient se poser sur sa
croupe
chez les all her cloisons en vol va pour
atterrir sur la croupe du cheval au
galop qui paraît franchir une colline
stylisé on voit en bas un chevron
surmonté d'une sphère
idem chez les novices avec un oiseau à
la queue en panache
et toujours le cheval saute par-dessus
quelque chose
chez les mails de l'oiseau atterri sur
le cheval qui passe ici par dessus un
obstacle arrondi en demi cercle
le cheval saut par-dessus trois cercles
comme ici chez les bituriges tandis que
l'oiseau aux ailes déployées va pour se
poser ou à gripper la croupe de ses
serres
sur cette magnifique monnaie des unelles
l'oiseau géant s'approche du cheval par
l'arrière il semble lâcher de son bec
une sphère
le cheval au galop piétine une créature
anthropomorphes qui al'allure d'un homme
serpent au bras levés et au corps
longiligne
la scène rappelle la statuaire des
colonnes à tard à nice où le cheval
piétine le monstre andy ped
le personnage piétiner ou traverser
parfois tout autre chez laisser quan
c'est un serpent par-dessus lequel bondi
le cheval
chez les aulerques le cheval saute par
dessus un sanglier qui lui même sur mon
une série de petits demi cercle
devant le cheval se trouve une sorte de
sphère lumineuse
chez les cadettes en revanche c'est le
sanglier qui tel un cocher montant
croupe le cheval
enfin signe abstrait accompagne le
cheval les s ici au dessus du cheval
sont associés à la roue
est-ce que l'on retrouve sur l'épaule de
taranis associé aussi à la roue solaire
qui la grippe dans sa main
cette monnaie db l'ovac présente sous le
ventre du cheval au galop une hélice ou
étoiles tournons à six bras
certains symboles parle vraiment de même
chez les zambiens le cheval est ici
surmonté de trois croissants de lune
certaines monnaies contiennent des mots
gaulois qui viennent éclairer le sens de
l'image et qui vont indirectement nous
ramener à tard à 10
chez la tribu des mails d' une monnaie
présente un cheval au galop qui saute
par dessus un obstacle arrondi sur la
croupe du cheval est posé un grand
oiseau aux ailes déployées
en bas la légende et pénos indique le
nom même du cheval en gaulois epos
signifie cheval le suffixe noces indique
une divinité et pénos et simplement
l'équivalent masculin de la célèbre ds
epona c'est le cheval divin
sur une monnaie de la tribu déçu et sion
le cheval a des ailes en bas est écrit
le mot critique ou peut-être faut-il y
voir la racine creek sauce chevelure
crépue ondulé un surnom en référence à
sa crinière
mais l'une des plus intéressantes
inscription est la suivante cette
monnaie des bituriges montre un cheval
au galop il est surmonté de trois
cercles en bas il y a le mot à budos
en celtique le radical abu des îles le
cours d'eau rivières ou fleuve
en complément on a le suffixe adjectiv
al dos
le cheval à budos et donc le cheval de
la rivière le cheval fluvial
chez la même tribu on trouve le mot abus
qu'atos avec la même racine pour
désigner le lien entre cheval y rivière
ainsi sept équidés qui galope sur les
monnaies gauloises est-il un cheval
divin et fluviales
et l'on devine que l'un de ses exploits
consiste à franchir une rivière
toutes ces monnaies forme donc les
témoins métallique d'un ancien me de
gaulois qui s'apparente beaucoup aux
cavaliers alanguie ped
si l'on tente d'en résumer les grands
lignes indus à cheval cavalier centaure
associés parfois à un oiseau et à des
éléments astro roux soleil lune traverse
où piétinent un monstre à terre rivière
humanoïdes serpent sangliers
les colonnes à taranis ne figure
apparemment pas d'oiseau mais leur
chapiteau sommitale exhibe un visage sur
chacune de ses quatre faces
ces quatre villes jeux située juste sous
le dieu aérien du tonnerre symbolise
peut-être les vents saisonniers des
quatre points cardinaux
ce qui en ferait à l'instar des oiseaux
des personnages aérien
sur le chaudron de garder ce truc
taranis est en tout cas clairement
associée à de puissants volatile des
griffons
ce divin cheval des anciens gaulois n'a
pas été englouti par les siècles
la matière de france en a conservé le
souvenir dans le cheval bayard que monte
en croupe les quatre fils aymon
bayard est en effet lié au monde de la
tempête à l'instar du cheval de taranis
qu'est le dieu du tonnerre
bayard à les sabots bruyant comme la
tempête
bayard al'allure d'un cheval volant à
l'instar des monnaies gauloises qui
présente un cheval pour vu d'elle
il semble à celui qui le voit que bayard
doit voler vous ne sied vue remuer ni
pieds ni jambes
enfin il ne manque à ce cheval que le
langage à l'instar des monnaies antiques
qui nous présente un cheval à visage
d'homme
vous le savez bien un noble seigneur
bayard le destrier aragon effet il
comprend la parole comme s'ils étaient
tom
et dans le v6 épique celui qui cherche à
s'approprier ce cheval fait n'est autre
que l'empereur charlemagne
l'un des principaux exploits du cheval
bayard consiste à gagner la course
hippique de montmartre qui a lieu à la
saint jean d'été
exploit qui permet à renault le chef des
cats frère de s'emparer de la couronne
de charlemagne avant de s'enfuir en
traversant la seine
la couronne royale est sertie d'une
pierre précieuse l'escarboucle que
renault fixera la cime de son château de
montauban renoue s'adresse ici à
charlemagne qui voudrait négocier sa
couronne
par dieu dit renaud cet accord ne
m'intéresse pas avec cet or je paierai
tout mais chevalier l'escarboucle je la
mettrais dans mon puissant palais de
loin ils pourront la voir flamboyer ceux
qui vont en galice pour prier saint
jacques quant à vous quand vous tiendrez
votre cours à noël et à pâques vos
nobles chevaliers vous ré prouveront de
l'avoir perdue pour avoir marchandé à
cheval
mounir al dik on figure l'escarboucle
par un cercle qui projette huit rayons
terminé en fleur de lys
plus tard charlemagne finit quand même
par s'emparer du cheval sont conseillés
name de bavière lé 8 souffle alors le
moyen de se débarrasser de cet animal
fabuleux
que le cheval soit jetée dans le rhin
avec une meule autour du cou
mais le destrier féerique est invincible
on apporte la meule qui pèsent lourd on
enferme et on attache le coût du
vaillant bayard dans la chaîne de faire
sa tête est poussé au centre de la meule
puis il est jeté avec appétit aux hits
et dans le rap profond mais le cheval
bayard attend gratter avec ses pattes
qu'il a cassé la meule et tronçonné le
faire il sort de l'eau à peine y est ils
demeuraient
finalement bayard surgi des flots
s'échappe et rejoint le magicien mogis
dans le mystérieux bois de là serpente
on retrouve clairement chez bayard les
mêmes éléments mythiques sur les
monnaies gauloises
le destrier est doublement liée à deux
thèmes bien précis la rule cercle qu'il
s'agisse de l'escarboucle en version
positive ou de la meule en négative et
le fleuve qu'il s'agisse de franchir la
seine après une victoire ou de surgir du
rhin après un supplice
sur les anciennes monnaies le cheval est
associée au fleuve nommément mais aussi
à plusieurs roues ou cercles peut-être
en référence à des épisodes de son
épopée conservés dans la chanson de
geste
le dieu à cheval qui piétinent
la terre est un mythe celtique présent
sur les monnaies gauloises d'avant notre
ère
et sur les colonnes à taranis de lempire
gaulois
et son parcours intemporel se poursuit
bien au delà comme par exemple dans du
mobilier religieux daté du haut
moyen-âge
au musée de dijon un ceinturon montre de
chevaux tirant un char stylisés comme
une grosse roue à dire et les chevaux
foule de leurs sabots une créature
renversé à terre
le char transporte un homme qui est au
dessus de la route il tient de la main
gauche un bâton surmonté d'un oiseau
tandis qu'il lève le bras droit
l'autre homme imposant et situe au
centre et comme recouvert d'une épaisse
cap on retrouve la composante principale
l'homme à cheval la roue l'oiseau est
l'ennemi informel piétiné à terre
c'est le même mythe que taranis écrasant
le monstre en type aide ou le centaure
renversant le monstre des monnaies
antiques de la gaule
le blanc manteau d'églises qui parsèment
l'occident l'an mil conserve ce mythe
celtique
l'église de parthenay le vieux dans les
deux sèvres présente sur sa façade ouest
deux au relief imposant qui encadrent
l'entrée au centre
ces deux scènes puissante qui semble se
compléter ne se réfère en rien à
l'évangile mais rappelle clairement les
deux actions principales du charlemagne
des chansons de geste à savoir d'abord
traverser à cheval un obstacle au sol
qu'on a identifié au fleuve en crue acte
d'autorité
ensuite victoire sur lyon à mains nues
acte de bravoure
à gauche le cavalier barbu et coiffé
d'un casque
sur sa main gauche il porte un oiseau
tandis qu'il tient les rênes de la main
droite
son cheval piétine un petit humanoïde
coucher au sol et recroquevillée sur le
dos
il n'y a aucune lutte mais un acte de
domination
on note la composante le trio homme
cheval oiseaux piétine l'ennemi à terre
cette scène très précises est identique
à un autre que l'on a vues soit sur les
monnaies gauloises antique avec le
centaure et les qui combine en lui même
les trois personnes homme cheval oiseaux
soit sur le ceinturon médiévale de dijon
avec les chevaux tirant le char le
cocher et l'oiseau perché sur le bâton
soit dans la légende de charlemagne qui
pour accomplir sa mission doit traverser
un fleuve l'ennemi informelle au sol
guider sur le chemin des toiles par
saint jacques qui remplit alors le rôle
de l'oiseau
l'autre scène de parthenay vieux
présente un relief très esquinté mais on
y devine la fameuse luttent à main nue
entre l'homme et le lion
c'est la composante l'homme combat le
lion en corps à corps
la correspondance est évidente entre le
cavalier de parthenay le vieux qui
piétine l'ennemi au sol et taralis à
cheval piétinant languit ted
et cette scène précise du cavalier
dominateurs contre l'ennemi plus ou
moins rampant se retrouve dans maintes
église celtique ou romanes
hamel lecavalier barbu domine de toute
la hauteur de son cheval un petit
personnage assis par terre
la tête du cavalier et ceinte d'une
couronne de lauriers tel un empereur en
triomphe à la façon d'auguste ou
charlemagne
quant au nord la tête renversée en
arrière il est tous tes cheveux les sa
posture témoigne de sa totale
résignation
à autun le cavalier barbu et coiffé
d'une couronne
son cheval piétine de son sabot droit
levé un homme accroupi dans les
feuillages
à brioude scènes identiques
le cavalier barbu en armure piétine du
sabot droit de son cheval un personnage
accroupi au sol
saint martin de boscherville leroy
cavaliers barbu porte une couronne son
allure fière irradie d'autorité des
sabots de son cheval il piétine 1-1
accroupi par terre
le nomme visage renfrogné mais résignée
abrite son crâne de ses bras contre les
sabots du cheval
leroy pointe devant lui son index en
direction d'une femme aux cheveux longs
comme le roi elle porte une couronne et
dans chaque main elle brandit haut un
grand lice
rennes semble simplement indiqué au roi
le chemin à suivre
structurellement la scène rappelle
beaucoup charlemagne sur la route de
compostelle
lors de sa traversée du fleuve à cheval
en effet le roi est guidé par une biche
bienveillant qui lui en indique le guet
ce rapprochement avec charlemagne se
justifie d'autant plus que sur le
chapiteau d'à côté un cavalier en armure
arrive sur un champ de bataille
il pointe son index vers le soleil
flamboyant
ce qui rappelle là encore charlemagne
juste après le désastre de roncevaux
l'empereur immobilise grâce à dieu le
soleil dans le ciel et peut ainsi vengé
son neveu roland en massacrant les
sarrasins
enfin pas fois les éléments semblent
séparer comme si l'on voulait montrer
les acteurs avant le dénouement final
à falaise un chapiteau montre le
cavalier portant une longue lance dans
sa main droite
sur le chapiteau d'un côté vers où se
dirige le cavalier une gueule à grippe
entre ses dents des serpents en
entrelacs
on reconnaît l'homme à cheval qui va au
devant de langui ped ou monstres à queue
de serpent
la composante trinitaire qui associe
homme cheval et oiseaux s'offre
immédiatement au regard sur des monnaies
gauloises avec la figure hybride du
centaure et les souvent comme on a vu ce
cheval sommes pourvus d'elle piétine de
ses sabots un humanoïde coucher au sol
aussi surprenant que cela puisse
paraître le centaure et les a traversé
les siècles sans prendre une ride
sur le portail sud de l'église d'aulnay
de saintonge
la créature triple subsiste de façon
identique à ce qu'elle est et sur les
monnaies de la gaule antique
en cette farandole féerique le centaure
et les fêtes une ruade et le voisinage
immédiat de ce cheval mythique confirme
la pérennité du mythe gaulois
à gauche avec sa queue de serpent le
dragon répond en écho à la créature à
queue de serpent que piétine le cheval
de taranis et la sirène qui le suit
symbole aquatique rappelle que ce
piétinement pourrait symboliser le
passage d'un cours d'eau
sur le même portail sud on trouve un
groupe assez approchons sur le plan
structurel le sagittaire voisine avec
une chouette tandis qu'il braque de son
arc un cervidé
le centaure chasseurs et la chouette
couvre à eux deux la composante homme
cheval oiseaux mais en version plus
nocturne
le plus souvent toutefois c'est sous la
forme de trois personnages distincts que
se présente l'équipage homme cheval
oiseaux qui paraît alors formé un trio
héroïque sur le ceinturon de dijon le
trio est formé du cocher de l'oiseau sur
le bâton et des deux chevaux tirant le
char
à graville lecavalier qui pourchasse le
cervidé est associé à un oiseau géant
juste derrière la croupe du cheval
à parthenay le vieux le trio se compose
du cavalier de son cheval et de l'oiseau
au poignet
dans le val d'oise l'église du hall me
présente un tympan avec le même trio
le héros galope sur son cheval il
brandit une bannière un oiseau le suit
qui va pour se poser sur la croupe du
cheval
l'oiseau qui volent juste au dessus de
la coupe du cheval a comme voyager dans
le temps
rencontre déjà ce duo fascinant sur les
monnaies de l'ancienne gaule
[Musique]
quand l'oiseau est gigantesque
ne serait-il pas amené à soulever le
cheval dans les airs
c'est ce que montre un chapiteau de
l'église de falaise l'oiseau géant
hagrid dans ses serres le cheval pour le
soulever en l'air
monnaies gauloises antique et chapiteaux
d'églises médiévales en vis-à-vis on
peine à croire que plus de mille ans
séparerait les deux images temps le
thème est identique
une chanson de geste va éclaircir cette
composante précise du cheval soulever
par l'oiseau géant
la chanson d'apremont raconte la
mythique bataille que charlemagne
aurélie vais en italie contre les
sarrasins
dans l'épisode qui nous intéresse le duc
name accompagné de son cheval noir morel
est envoyés en ambassade chez l'ennemi
pour mener à bien sa mission il lui faut
franchir un périlleux cole en haute
montagne
ceinturée d'une nature hostile et
neigeuses l'équipage équestre va
accomplir deux exploits
d'abord traversé la froid de rivière
près d'une cascade
exploit réussi grâce à la hardiesse du
cheval
leduc name de bavière s'en va désormais
porter le message aux sarrasins il
chevauche vers apremont quand commence à
tomber ainsi fort grésil que la neige
recouvre bientôt le coût de son destrier
leduc s'approche d'une roche à brut d'où
descendent les eaux impossible de
trouver planches ni gay voyez donc ce
que fait le noble duc il rassemble ses
forces et peut rendre le cheval et se
jette dans l'eau plus profond de la
rivière ainsi parvient-il sur l'autre
rive
la haute montagne et le repère des
grands volatile
le griffon est un oiseau géant apparenté
à l'aide
[Musique]
menthe église gauloise représente le
griffon créatures qui à l'avant d'un
aigle et l'arrière d'un lion
il est figurée de même en héraldique
et déjà sur le chaudron de garder ce
trip auprès de taranis
dès qu'il aperçoit le cheval et son
cavalier le rapace fond sur l'intrus
de ces immenses auxerre il va gripper
morel et le soulevé dans les airs
name devra trancher les glyphes du
griffon pour pouvoir atteindre le sommet
de la montagne
le griffon arrivants volant il saisit
aussitôt morel qui sont le sable ils
lèvent à trois pieds du sol puis le
laisse violemment retombé la tête
tournée du côté où était la croupe pour
s'en sortir le duke extrait son épée au
pommeau d'or et un frappe le griffon et
que nos telle vigueur qui lui coupe les
deux pieds à la fois la pâte et plus
grosses qu'on ne croit on mettrait dans
la prive des litres de vin n'aime la
prend pour la montrer à charlemagne à
force de grappes et le duc parvient au
sommet d'apremont
ainsi la composante l'oiseau soulève le
cheval se rencontrent à la fois sur des
monnaies gauloises
sur des chapiteaux d'église et dans la
geste de charlemagne
quant à la composante le cheval et il le
monstre allongé au sol elle offre des
similitudes frappantes entre taranis et
ces survivances médiévale le cheval de
taranis piétine l'humanoïde à queue de
serpent de façon très similaire à
parthenay le vieux le cheval du cavalier
piétine l'humanoïde au sol sur le
ceinturon de dijon les chevaux du char
piétine l'humanoïde au sol quant au
cheval de même il ne piétine pas mais
traverse la rivière enneigées il semble
que l'ennemi chtonien piétiné par les
sabots du cheval soit la figuration
esthétique d'un thème bien précis la
traversée équestre du serpent d'eau
qu'est la rivière
hypothèse confirmée non seulement par
l'exploit donne m sur son cheval morel
mais aussi par la monnaie par langue des
bituriges où l'on voit le cheval en
plein galop bondir au dessus de la
légende à budos que l'on traduit par le
cheval de la rivière
[Musique]
dès lors on comprend pourquoi en général
l'équipage équestre est l'obstacle
passif au sol ne sont pas représentés en
duel frontal
il s'agit en fait d'un exploit
d'affirmation du cavalier qui est en
train de franchir un cours d'eau
difficile
de manière intéressante même franchit la
rivière sous la neige détail narratif
qui n'est sans doute pas anodin ce lien
entre la traversée et la neige indique
peut-être le franchissement saisonniers
de l'hiver
thür une monnaie des aulerques la
figuration anticipe de façon saisissante
laventure donne m le cheval au galop
paraît franchir une colline symbolisée
ici par un chevron tandis qu'un oiseau
aux ailes déployées va pour agripper sa
croupe
l'altitude de la scène joue aussi un
rôle
ainsi pour même la traversée de la
rivière glacée coïncide avec l'arrivée
au sommet d'apremont
de même pour taranis le piétinement de
langui ped coïncide avec le sommet de la
colonne
la synthèse de toutes ces données
mythique se trouve peut-être sur le
chaudron de gains des strips
une plaque présente quatre cavaliers
il galope sur un arbre couché dont les
racines son côté qu bo géant à gauche et
le sommet côté serpent et carnyx à
droite
le trio homme cheval oiseaux se voit à
droite sous la forme d'un cheval monté
par un homme dont le casque est orné
d'un oiseau
notre cavalier arrive donc sur une
hauteur la cime de l'arbre et il se
retrouve face aux serpents tel taranis
sur sa colonne piétinant la créature
serpentiforme nm sur la première
franchissant la rivière
autant de la gaule tribal maintenait
figure le cheval à visages d'hommes qui
tire un charme hanté par un cocher
l'équipage peu
une créature allongé au sol qui paraît
lui faire obstacle
pire romain ou gaulois le dieu cavaliers
taranis reprend cette thématique du haut
de sa colonne
son cheval piétine de ses sabots
l'humanoïde en forme de serpent
homme cheval et l'oma cheval semble donc
parfois représenter le même personnage
même si les termes sont plus ou moins
interchangeables il existe une
différence entre le cheval à visages
d'hommes qui a quatre membres
et le centaure proprement dit qui
dispose de deux bras en plus ce qui lui
fait six membres
des vessies mythique très différents les
autres devaient mettre en scène des
centaures des épisodes évidemment sans
rapport avec la bible
[Musique]
à mauzac 200 tort encadrent un arbre
chacun présente dans ses mains un gros
fruits en forme de pomme de pain
en auvergne le duo de centaures et
fréquemment associée à l'arbre
soit il fait la cueillette des fruits
soit ils présentent les feuillages
à glen montaigu 200 tort tiennent chacun
dans leurs mains un laurens ou en
entrelacs aux pointes fleurdelisé
à charlieu le centaure affrontant duel
lecavalier chacun tirant la barbe de
l'autre
au puy en velay le centaure celui-là
sans torres aux longs cheveux
le centaure tient un bâton dans la main
droite et agrippe de la main gauche là
que retroussé de la santé res
là sans torres n'a aucune poitrine et
s'écoute sont ressortis en signe de
maigreur
acune au un centaure barbu tenant une
arme dans sa main droite affronte un
humanoïde en armure qui rampe comme un
insecte
or glabre brandi une arme et va pour
affronter un ours humaniser tenus en
laisse
derrière le sang
des oiseaux à tête d'homme comme souvent
cheval hommes et oiseaux sont ici
associés
toutes ces figurations de centaur ne
correspond pas forcément aux mêmes
personnages mais il est frappant de
constater combien nos églises médiévales
ont conservé la physionomie du centaure
déjà présente sur les monnaies de la
gaule antique il s'en dégage une
évidente continuité culturelle sur le
temps long
dans la mythologie antique gauloise deux
figures masculines semble dominer le
panthéon payen tard à nice
et kern une hausse
de même dans la matière de france un
lien étroit existant entre le roi à
cheval et le cervidé
ainsi quand charlemagne clovis doit
traverser une rivière en crue il obtient
l'aide décisive du cervidé qu'il invite
à le suivre et lui indique l'emplacement
du gué
le fait de suie de poursuivre le cervidé
est donc l'une des actions fondamentales
du roi des francs à cheval
qui donne la composante suivante l'homme
à cheval cavalier ou sans oeuvre
poursuit le cerf
dans les églises anciennes on retrouve
beaucoup de scènes de chasse qui
évidemment n'a aucun lien avec la bible
le binôme homme cheval contre cervidés y
est fréquent un grave il on se souvient
du cavalier à la roue qui jouxte de
cervidés en train de paître
un chapiteau voisin fait sans doute
référence aux mêmes récits qui présente
ici une scène de chasse complète
ce cavalier poursuit un cervidé sans
ramure
l'animal paraît déjà blessé douce et
j'ai qui jaillissent de son dos
le cavalier est ici associé un oiseau
géant situé derrière lui
l'oiseau détourne sa tête en arrière
tandis qu'il saisit d'une serre le tronc
d'un arbre
à gauche un chien se retourne vers la
scène de chasse
on note que le chien et loison des
attitudes symétrique
l'oiseau a le corps tourné vers la
chasse mais détourne le visage le chien
semble au contraire s'apprêtait à
répondre à l'appel
cette poursuite du cervidé par un
cavalier accompagné d'un oiseau et d'un
chien est riche d'enseignements la
séquence trouve en effet un écho
favorable dans les textes du charlemagne
légendaire où les mêmes personnages
devenus parfois des humanoïdes joue un
rôle identique
le cerf est poursuivi par charlemagne
qui trouvent ainsi le gué pour traverser
la gironde
l'oiseau devient l'âme volante qui
conseille le roi tel saint jacques qui
dans un songe montre à charlemagne la
voie lactée
quant au chien il devient le héros de
force c'est sous la forme d'un chien que
dans un songe relance cours charlemagne
à l'abbaye de saint benoît sur loire
sous le porche on reconnaît les mêmes
personnages homme cheval chiens oiseaux
et cervidés présenté ici avec une
esthétique plus dynamique
le cavalier pour chats sert le cheval
les deux pattes le vph est une ruade
un côté le chien la gueule ouverte bondi
vers la croupe du cervidé qui s'enfuit
la tête retournée il est déjà atteint
d'une lance
le cavalier souffle son cor de chasse
sa main droite surdimensionné est tendu
vers l'arrière sous sa main un crj
apparemment mort les pattes
recroquevillé près d'un arbuste
si l'on prend un peu d espace on note
chapiteau adjacent des figures
intéressante à gauche un homme brandit
dans ses mains une mystérieuse tête
ronde soit laquelle on va revenir et à
droite sur la frise des duos d'oiseaux
mange des brindilles au milieu des
feuillages
le cavalier est donc accompagné d'un
chien en pleine action tandis que non
loin des oiseaux assiste passivement à
la chasse au cerf
la gestuelle offre aussi un avantage à
mettre en perspective avec d'autres
figuration
la main droite du cavalier de fleury et
d'une grandeur inhabituelles comme si
l'artiste avait voulu lui donner un sens
particulier il la tient à la fois en
hauteur est très en arrière
un peu à la manière du cavalier de grave
il est toujours en présence de deux
cervidés
et chaque main droite n'est pas isolé
elle jouxte et surmontent soit la
fameuse roue à graville soit le sert
déjà mort à fleury
à fleury une sorte de tête roues se
situe en arrière du cavalier
dressez parmi les feuillages un homme
tient dans ses mains une tête coupée
énorme et toutes rondes qu'il offre au
public comme un trophée
on dit est exagéré de cette tête n'en
font pas une tête humaine mais plutôt la
tête d'une créature mythologique comme
s'il s'agissait du soleil ou de la lune
ainsi les deux abbayes ont représenté le
même récit
et est associé à deux cervidés et sa
main droite est tendue en arrière vers
une roue
les liens avec taranis sont évidents le
chaudron de guindé ce truc présente en
effet le dieu gaulois soit brandissant
de ses bras de cervidés soit associée à
une roue qu'il tient dans sa main droite
quant à charlemagne on sait qu'il est
associé aux cervidés pour franchir le
fleuve et qui l'immobilisent larusso
l'air après sa prière à dieu
le héros de la chasse au cerf n'est pas
seulement le cavalier mais aussi le cerf
c'est pourquoi fleuri sur un autre
chapiteau c'est le cervidé qui est mise
en vedette il trône à la cime des
feuillages accompagné sur la frise de
duos d'oiseaux qui s'enlacent par le
coup
maintes autres églises présentes la même
configuration avec plus ou moins de
ressemblance par exemple à falaise on
voit le cavalier au galop il souffle son
énorme cors de chasse
devant le chasseur à cheval court les
deux chiens
sont sur les traces du cervidés qui
retourne la tête vers ses poursuivants
fréquemment à la place du cavalier sur
son cheval c'est le centaure qui
pourchasse lecerf
saint parize le châtel est située en
bourgogne à 20 km au sud de nevers
l'église de surface et quelconque mais
ça petit clip est remarquable
à l'entrée de la crypte le choc
droite présente un sagittaire le
centaure casque et brandit son arc et sa
flèche
au-dessus de la croupe du sagittaire se
trouve une tortue
derrière le sagittaire il y à un ciapol
un unijambiste assis par terre qui
remonte son immense pied par dessus sa
tête si apod adossé à un appui végétale
ou est perché une chouette
le sagittaire est ici un chasseur
la flèche du sagittaire a déjà atteint
le cerf à l'épaule droite on envoie la
pointe rejaillir
la patte blessée monte sur un appui qui
ressemble à un tronc d'arbre buste
face aux serres un acrobate fait une
roue arrière de son corps ses mains
agrippant ses chevilles on note que le
pied de l'acrobate touche le même appui
que la patte blessée du cerf
l'homme roux voisine avec la chouette
cet homme qui fait la roue est peut-être
la réminiscence du héros qui tient la
roue avec taranis sur le chaudron de
guerre des strips
brou fait ici une roue en arrière ce qui
n'est pas sans rappeler le soleil dont
on a vu que la course est soit inversé
par jupiter taranis dans le panégyrique
de mamertin soit arrêtée par charlemagne
dans la chanson de rolland
à l'entrée de la crypte se présente
aussi une roue à six rayons encadré de
deux spirales
cette route dominante est situé en face
du sagittaire
l'association homme cheval et roux
ramène à tard à nice
par anis qui est comme notre sagittaire
un chasseur de cervidés
le sagittaire chasse ray très fréquent
dans nos églises celtique à espalion il
a déjà atteint d'une flèche à
quadrupèdes qui tentent de fuir et il
arme une nouvelle flèche ils portent ici
un carquois à l'épaule
grâce à son d'une grande souplesse le
sagittaire peut se retourner ce qui lui
donne alors une posture rétrograde à
vézelay sur un pilier d'entrée le
centaure à l'arrêt se retourne et
brandit arcs et flèches vers le dehors
ça que retroussé entre les pattes lui
remonte sur le dos
à graville le sagittaire se retourne et
vis de sa flèche le lion qui le mort à
la queue
hamel le sagittaire se retourne et vis
de sa flèche le cervidé qui le suit
à saint martin de boscherville le
sagittaire se retourne et vise de sa
flèche le cervidé qui est posée sur sa
croupe
en astrologie le sagittaire et le signe
zodiacal qui finit l'année solaire quand
ils se présentent en posture rétrograde
il galope vers un bout de l'année tout
en visant l'autre bout de l'année
les modillons bien qu'indépendant les
uns des autres présentent parfois des
scènes en correspondance ainsi un reto
le sagittaire arme son arc vers
l'arrière et vise le modillons d'à côté
où sa précédente flèche vient
d'atteindre un cerf qui le fuyait
l'église d'aulnay de saintonge en
charente maritime présente un portail
sud magnifique
là vous sur rillieux rallye une
farandole ferrique d'une trentaine de
personnages insolites qui se suivent à
la queue leu leu
la plupart des personnages sont tournés
vers l'extérieur ceux de gauche vers la
gauche ceux de droite vers la droite
trois d'entre nous intéresse
le sagittaire dressé sur ses pattes
arrière se retourne et arm son arc en
direction du cerf
de l'autre côté du sagittaire il y à une
chouette
sagittaire cervidés et chouette
composent un trio précis déjà vu sur un
chapiteau de saint parize le châtel il
existe donc une composante le sagittaire
poursuit le cerf aux côtés d'une
chouette
c'est la trinité homme cheval oiseaux
ici à la poursuite du cervidé
l'antique dieu taranis et aso c'est à la
fois au cheval comme sur les colonnes
impérial
à la route solaire et aux cervidés sur
le chaudron de garder ce truc
si l'on associe tous ces éléments qui
représente par anis
on obtient la composante suivante le
cavalier à la roue s'empare du cervidé
à l'église de graville on a vu un relief
de cet ordre le cavalier brandi vers
l'arrière son épée juste sous laquelle
se trouve une roue et sous ce cavalier à
la roue pesce de cervidés
à saint martin de boscherville la roue
et même dominante
orientée plein sud elle confirme son
essence solaire la roue se situe
derrière le sagittaire qui vise de sa
flèche le cervidé posée sur sa croupe
à saint benoît sur
scènes de chasse apparaît au milieu des
feuillages un homme qui porte dans ses
mains une grosse et mystérieuse tête
ronde en forme de roue
à saint parize le châtel face au
sagittaire chasseurs trône une roue
classique à cirer
la roue l'homme cheval et le cerf forme
clairement la base d'un récit payen
celtique
et cette composante homme cheval auroux
cervidés à la fois antique et médiévale
est aussi présente on le sait dans la
geste du charlemagne légendaire
en résumé les 3 matières mythique se
rejoignent dans la matière en tic
taranis du à cheval est associée à la
route solaire et aux cervidés
dans la matière médiéval le cavalier ou
le centaure est associée à la roue et
aux cervidés
enfin dans la matière de france
charlemagne roi à cheval est associée à
la route soleil qui l'immobilisent et il
traverse la gironde derrière un cervidé
il est donc clair que la mythologie du
dieu taranis sait conserver à la fois
dans le décor des églises celtique avec
notamment un certain cavaliers à la roue
et dans la geste légendaire de
charlemagne
chez charlemagne l'apparition du cervidé
est clairement lié à la traversée de la
surface dos à cheval
chez taranis les deux éléments sont
présents soit taranis piétinent à cheval
languit ped ce que l'on a rapproché de
la traversée de la rivière
soit aramis et le cervidé sont associés
sans lien toutefois avec une surface
doit traverser
mais existe-t-il sur le
10 trucs la composante le cervidé et la
traversée de l'eau à cheval
sur la plaque de cairns une hausse on
note la présence discrète d'un petit
personnage
un homme chevauche un poisson
à l'évidence le héros traverse une
étendues aquatiques en posture de
cavaliers
cette plaque de karni noces associe donc
les éléments suivants le cervidé le
héros en posture de cavaliers mais ce
héros est ici juché sur un poisson pour
indiquer qu'il traverse une surface
d'eau
comme on pouvait s'y attendre nos
églises celtique gardons en mémoire
cette traversée de l'eau sur un poisson
ainsi à mauzac dans le puy de dôme on
reconnaît le même équipage l'homme
chevauche un poisson et tient ici dans
sa main quelque chose de difficile à
identifier un pain ou un paquet
odyssée aquatiques que l'on retrouve
exemple à orcival
la ressemblance est frappante
alliés aux poissons ce qui soulève là
encore la question de la datation de ces
oeuvres
quelle distance temporelle sépare
vraiment mauzac du chaudron de garder ce
truc
tu réellement la chevauchée du poisson
est l'équivalent du cheval piétinant une
créature passive coucher au sol comme on
le voit appartenait le vieux
dans les deux cas en effet l'artiste a
dû trouver une astuce esthétique pour
figurer la traversée de l'eau à cheval
soit par un cavalier qui piétine une
créature passif coucher au sol tel
taranis en colonne où le cavalier de
parthenay le vieux soit par un homme à
cheval sur un poisson comme sur le
chaudron de garder streep ou à mauzac
enfin preuve qu'il s'agit bien du même
thème sous jacent on note qui
appartenait le vieux lecavalier piétine
heures fait précisément le pendant du
lutteur ou lyon les deux personnages
encadrent l'entrée ouest
or à mauzac sur le même chapiteau et
encadrants ici un arbre le cavalier
aquatique fait le pendant lui aussi dû
lutter au lion
on voit le héros victorieux il domine le
fauve qui est dos au sol et lui tient la
gueule ouverte
quant au chaudron de garder strubbe sur
deux plaques on reconnaît là même
complémentarité
la traversée aquatique à cheval sur un
poisson et la lutte à mains nues contre
un lion
l'affiliation culturelle saute aux yeux
entre l'art celtique antique et l'art
celtique des églises médiévales
pourvu de sa célèbre barbu i et ii sa
route solaire le roi des dieux s'en
aller jadis sur le chemin des toiles
traversant à cheval le fleuve hivernale
il répondait son autorité à tout
l'univers le charlemagne légendaire
procède tout droit de l'ancien tard à
nice